[Music]
hey wisecrack fleshie Jared again and
today we're breaking down season 3
episode 9 of Rick and Morty the ABCs of
bet this episode is one of my favorites
not only because it develops Beth in
some interesting ways but because it
builds on a theme from way back in
another season three favorite that idea
the importance of choice welcome this
wisecrack quick take on the ABCs of bed
first a quick recap the father of Beth's
adolescent friend Tommy is about to be
put to death for eating his son
Beth soon realizes her childhood fantasy
of Ruby land was not some mechanism to
cope with her friend's death but a very
real place built by Rick to keep her
sociopathic tendencies out of his way
also Tommy has built a kingdom on incest
and cannibalism I suppose you're
wondering how do I sustain myself
we aren't meanwhile Jerry has a new
alien girlfriend Kiara and things are
moving fast does your planet have
shorter days because you guys aren't
moving kind of fast no Jerry decides to
break up with her but is unable to take
responsibility for his decision and
blames his kids after Kiara tries to
murder morning and summer for allegedly
causing the break-up Jerry finally owns
up to his actions in the ABCs of bet the
a and B plots parallel each other we
have Beth Jerry and even Greg unwilling
to take responsibility for their choices
Beth refuses to acknowledge sentencing
Tommy to a life of humping Teletubbies
Tommy I'm sorry you think you deserve an
apology and Rick denies building fruit
peel and to avoid being emotionally
available to his daughter I'm sorry
you think you deserve an apology whereas
Jerry refuses to take responsibility for
ending his toxic relationship with Kiara
so what does all this have to do with
pickle Rick well this and I think it's
because the only truly unapproachable
concept for you is that it's your mind
within your control you chose to come
here you chose to talk to belittle my
vocation just as you chose to become a
pickle each of us gets to choose as
we've mentioned before this season is
playing a lot with the ideas of agency
freedom and
most importantly choice as dr. Wong
noted in Rick man Singh the stone Morty
is angry at his father for having no
agency in pickle Rick Rick literally
gives up his freedom by becoming a
pickle an elaborate ruse to avoid
therapy in the Rick Landis mix-up we see
what happens when Rick's give up their
freedom and of course in the world
leader Lee conspiracy one of my favorite
moments in the season is this advice to
Jerry but there comes a time in every
man's life when he must choose the
foundation on which his legacy will be
built one of compromise one of blood in
our pickle Rick quick take we talked
about how some of the ideas represented
there mirrored John Paul Sartre idea of
bad faith for a very quick refresher bad
faith is when we negate the radical
freedom we were afforded in our ability
to make choices in a sense we choose not
to choose after she realizes she's no
different than Rick Beth has an identity
crisis dad I'm out of excuses to not be
Who I am so Who am I what do I do
so how do ii sanchezes cursed with
intelligence find meaning in an uncaring
world am i evil worse
you're smart when you know nothing
matters the universe is yours
and I've never met a universe that was
into it Rick's conversation reflects on
some of sart's points for sart's the
whole problem of our existence starts
with the fact that there is no inherent
meaning and departing from start a bit
any it's have to draw meaning from the
universe will be met with cosmic
indifference you know smart people get a
chance to climb on top take reality for
a ride but it'll never stop trying to
throw you and eventually it will there's
no other way off for Rick though smart
enough get to take reality for a ride
before they too are inevitably thrown
off or in other words they can indulge
in whatever they desire but when reality
catches up with them well we've seen it
before with Rick Beth feels trapped by
her family
her arguably ironic attachment to ABC's
bachelors she readily denies her own
freedom and thus the choices available
to her with the facts of her existence
do that the kids Jerry my job and as
much as I hate to admit it ABC's The
Bachelor
Rick's solution isn't to free her
necessarily but to give her a choice can
make a clone of you a perfect instance
of you with all your memories an exact
copy in every way it'll love and provide
for the kids do your job and consume
broadcast network reality TV on the same
allegedly ironic level as you you could
be gone a day a week or the rest of your
life with zero consequences the moment
you decide to come back I flip a switch
and the clones job is done it feels no
pain regrets nothing and has zero chance
of going Blade Runner the important
thing here is Rick doesn't argue that
she should do this but says then stay
and luxuriate in a life you can finally
know you've chosen my secret bonus is
that no matter what you choose you're
finally gonna chill the [ __ ] out in
other words it's not whether she takes
Rick up on the clone or not but the fact
that she makes a choice that matters the
prospect of the clone confronts Beth
with her absolute freedom and just by
putting her in this crossroads Rick is
prompting her to choose her identity so
no matter what she chooses the choice
brings resolved or her identity crisis
so maybe Rick has learned something from
dr. Wong after all we can split hairs on
reddit forums for hours on whether or
not Beth decided to take Rick's offer
but it doesn't really matter whether or
not Beth abandoned her family it's the
fact that she chose that will ultimately
help her find meaning so what about evil
Jerry claims he isn't evil but just a
coward meanwhile Rick tells Beth she's
not evil just smart but are we to
believe Rick or is this for intelligence
used to justify sickness to quote dr.
Wong after all Rick built a magical play
place for his sociopathic child is to
avoid dealing with her inherited
problems to hear us address these
questions and more check out our Rick
and Morty podcast the Squatch we're
breaking down every episode of this
season of Rick and Morty so click on the
link in the description to get your
squanch on thanks for watching everybody
[Music]